alors je vous en parlais en début
d'émission j'espère que vous connaissez
les champs de Noël sur le bout des
doigts je sais que Clara vous êtes très
forte en blind test George Schmith vous
êtes un professionnel de la flûte de Pan
vous avez 11 disques d'or vous avez
travaillé avec Eno moricon pour le
cinéma la publicité également la Cosma
Eno moricon
j'en vous avez donné des concerts dans
le monde entier pas le monde entier mais
fait presque les CIN continents quand
même
ouais est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
une petite démonstration en direct comme
ça oh ben
oui tiens on va essayer de deviner on va
essayer de deviner le Mor c'est pas Noë
ou il une moricon ah
mission il l'avait en régie ré
appartient à cés vous AZ le droit de
jouer
aussi je vous propose qu'on continue
avec un un blind test mais plutôt sur
les sur les champs de Noël est-ce qu'on
fait des teams ou c'est le premier qui
répond je pense qu'on peut faire le
premier qui répond c'est parfaita va
gagner à chaque fois là Noël donc juste
vous avez changer de FL vous en avez
pris une grand diff parce que je
fabrique j'ai l'avantage de fabriquer
toutes mes Flut de Pan qui sont
accordables comme je fa beaucoup de
concerts en Église Flut de Pan et org
essentiellement aucun org en France
n'est accordé exactement pareil
normalement c'est le diapason 440
maintenant enfin c'est la la fréquence
mais les anciens orges de 1700 1800 il
sont un ton en dessous souvent alors
j'ai eu l'idée de remplacer la cire
d'abeille qu'on utilisait
traditionnellement par des piston qui
fait dans chaque tube j'ai mis voyez il
y a une tige filtée avec cette tige
filté j'ai des pistons en liège avec un
écrou qui est serti à à la base de
chaque piston qui permet de descendre ou
de monter les les piston alors en Alsace
les orges sont toujours très bas alors
je descends les je m'accorde en fonction
de et ça c'est un gain de temps
considérable et je c'est vrai je gagne
beaucoup de temps
euh pour accorder mes flutes ce soit
pour la publicité pour le
cinéma pas allez-y allez-y allez-y
allez-y on vous écoute Noë euh
alors c'est une publicité on déjà dit
Herta exactement exactement bien joué à
Patrick jacqu de dixm Sal en
[Musique]
ré passo
non les mar euh ben j'ai fait toutes les
séries hein Nescafé Herta
chamboursy Caprice des Dieux aussi je me
souviens plus alors souvent je rentre en
studio on met la partition sous les yeux
et puis euh lorsque je vais passer des
fois une demi-journée enregistrer faut
que ça tombe pile en fonction de l'image
et puis dès que je sors du studio j'ai
souvent oublié mais puis ça quand je
l'entends des fois ça peut être vous
joué tellement au final ben j'ai
énormément un moment où parce que
lorsquil av besoin de sons réel de flit
de maintenant c'est fait avec des
synthétiseurs ça pas tout à fait le même
son bon mais c'est pas grave et comme
c'est une émission spéciale Noël est-ce
que vous pouvez nous faire au moins un
chant de Noël oui
[Musique]
oui
alors est-ce qu'on a la réponse
rép ch Noël
allemand en tout ça pas l'air si simple
que ça on voit que vous avez bien quand
même il y a des petits TR mais vous
savez quand j'ai j'ai obligé j'ai pas le
choix he et vous avez commencé à quel
âge alors j'avais une vingtaine d'années
j'ai découvert la flute de pain à
travers le folklore d'Amérique du Sud
d'Europe centrale et puis j'ai eu l'idée
d'abord de décorer ma chambre mais
vraiment peu de temps après je me suis
dit pourquoi est-ce que j'en jouerais
pas et puis voilà je jouis la flute à fl
traversière avant et j'ai abandonné
vraiment tous les autres instruments et
vous avez appris seul ou vous êtes for
oui j'aiavis pas le choix j'ai appris
seul j'ai un peu appris avec zamphy je
zamphy le le bon et euh j'étais devenu
un concurrent direct dommage enfin c'est
c'est pas vraiment le cas mais bon je
voulais plus me recevoir l'élève a
dépassé le maître non non non j'ai pas
cette prétention et alors apparemment
vous pouvez aussi imiter le bruit d'une
flute avec seulement vos mains est-ce
que vous pouvez nous montrer seulement
vos mains oui mais pour ça je pris le MI
ah
pardon
[Musique]
et ceterael voulait
essayer super
impressionné on a tous enfin je pense la
plupart d'entre nous on a lorsqu'on
était gamin on a essayé de faire imiter
le LEB oui la chouette moi j'ai jamais
réussi hein voilà et je me suis rendu
compte qu' en mode on a essayé en
modulant on peut obtenir des sons
différents et j'ai quasiment deux
octaves comme ça mais ça se travaille
aussi c'est pareil mais voilà c'est
alors j'ai j'ai fait quand j'étais gamin
j'ai fait j'étais passionné partout
l'ornitologie j'ai fait beaucoup de je
voulais être ornitologue quand j'étais
gamin
[Musique]
ouis vous avez de multiples talents en
fait
voilà et alors juste pourquoi est-ce
qu'on appelle ça la flute de pan alors
c'est parce que c'est d'après la
mythologie grecque c'est le dieu Pan qui
poursuivait les nymp syrinx et puis un
jour elle s'est enfuie prise de frayeur
et elle s'est transformé en roseau alors
le Diop pris ces rosau les a attrapé
enfin les a découpé et en différentes
longueurs comme ceci et il a assemblé
donc ces tubes s'est aperçu qu'en
soufflant dans chaacun des tuyaux que
l'on pouit faire descendre donc on a
appelé depuis cet instrument une flute
de pain ou syring en hommage à celle qui
avait été coupée en petit morceau voilà
c'est pourquoi l'origine du mot panique
vient du grec pan panique Panicos pan ok
vous connaissez l'histoire en plateau
pas du tout pas du tout voilà on en
apprend tous les jour beauoup moi j'ai
fait beaucoup de parce que je suis agréé
par l'éducation national j'ai fait
beaucoup de spectacles jeune public et
c'est vraiment ça me vraiment ça me fait
énormément plaisir de retrouver à
travers toute la France hein quand je
vais jouer de retrouver des enfants
adultes maintenant qui viennent avec
leurs enfants me disant vous êtes venu
dans mon collège ou dans mon école et ça
ça fait vraiment plaisir quoi et
d'ailleurs si on veut vous voir en
concert ce sera début janvier dans le
Ain du côté de mulouseous j'ai pas dans
les Yvelines ce sera quand les
prochaines dates le 2 mars à
Saint-Germain en lait c'est un gros
concert
c'est au profit des des enfants et des
femmes
battues c'est organisé par le Lyon club
des de Saint-Germain
ou la grande église en du château hein
justement là où était Régine tout à
l'heure ah VO merci beaucoup encore
George Schmith vous restez avec nous
puisqu'on va parler de produits
yvelinois qu'on peut mettre à notre
table de Noel